welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is scus Docker and I'm
here with Roman yampolsky Roman is a
professor of computer science at the
University of Louisville Roman welcome
to the podcast thanks for inviting me
again we are here to talk about your
forthcoming book called AI unexplainable
unpredictable uncontrollable this is
some this is a very dense book there's a
lot in there so we as I told you we have
a lot to talk about I think what we
should we we could we could start at the
very surface level which is just the
cover of the book so so the cover is a
shocko meme or a Sho meme I'm not
certain how that's pronounced but it's
it's basically this kind of like love
crafty and monster octopus creature that
humans are then putting masks on so
maybe you want to explain what that
means and whether that is you know is
that your view of of
AI yeah so that's a classic meme the
idea is that we have this role model a
monster really just we know it's nasty
but what we're trying to do is kind of
make it look pretty put some lipstick on
it smiley face so a lot of it is
filtering don't say this word don't do
this but under the hood it's still
completely uncontrolled completely alien
creature to me at least this feels like
a lot of modern AI safety work is all
about that make it feel kind of safe and
secure but it's not really changing
overall safety of the system people may
perceive this as being kind of a a
hyperbolic meme you know if you have if
you're describing AI as a shock off but
then you go to chat gbt and you say okay
this this feels more like a tool this
doesn't even feel that agentic to me so
where is where's the path from current
AI to to this more kind of shogo like
AI well it's degrees of capability
versus Danger right if it's a neros
system it will fail in some ways but
they're very limited we're not going to
have existential crisis because it uses
incorrect word or misspells something
trivial things as it gets more capable
the impact from mistakes accidents
errors will become proportionately
larger and if it becomes fully General
then it can make mistakes across
multiple domains and impact is
equivalent or exceeds that from Human
agents but you would describe the
foundational models underlying chat gbt
or the open source models or or any of
these proprietary models as being
fundamentally sh like in that they can't
be explained or they we don't understand
how they work basically still well there
are certain things we obviously know
about them but uh we need complete
understanding if you're engineering a
system we're kind of used to knowing
every brick every wire where does it go
why is it there what happens if if you
remove it here we train it on all of
Internet basically all human knowledge
and then once we're done training it we
experiment on it to see what can it do
what are the dangerous behaviors but
once we discover we try to mitigate that
doesn't seem like it's going to get you
Safety and Security at a level something
so capable needs to be controlled your
book is a description of a number of
features that we can't get with AI so we
we can't get predictability for example
we can't get
explainability maybe if we if we start
with unpredictability why is it
fundamentally speaking that we can't
predict AI Behavior with
certainty so we can predict certain AI
behaviors it's just we can't predict all
of them with a necessary degree of
precision and the proof is Trivial if
you have something smarter than you the
assumption is you you are not that smart
so you can't make decisions the system
makes or predict them playing chess is a
classic example if I can perfectly
predict what my opponent is going to do
in any situation I'm playing at the same
level but the assumption is they a
better player so it's violation of our
initial assumptions if we cannot predict
how smarter than human agent will
accomplish its goals in particular so
maybe we know overall direction the
terminal goal it's trying to achieve but
we don't know how it gets there is
possible there are some very significant
negative side effects from obtaining the
final goal but at the cost of many
things we're not willing to sacrifice to
get there but we can make uncertain
predictions right if you're if you're an
investor uh deciding which companies to
invest in you wouldn't say that because
we can't make certain predictions about
which companies are going to be most
valuable we shouldn't you know uncertain
predictions is the norm in in any domain
I would think absolutely and then you
investing you happy to be guaranteed you
know 80% chance of making good money 20%
chance maybe you lose your principle
here we're talking about all of humanity
so if there is 1% chance we're all going
to die is the payout let's say Free
Labor worth it and that's a decision I
don't remember voting on some people are
trying to make it for us could these
uncertain predictions be good enough for
for policy or say good enough for for
technical guarantees or reinsurances
that systems are functioning like they
should in my opinion no so if you're
talking about a system which can kill
everyone or Worse what level of
confidence do you need to decide to run
that system to me it has to be basically
100% safety that's not attainable I know
that that is not the standard we ever
get in software usually with software we
click yes I agree to whatever
consequences and we move on if it fails
to perform as expected it's not a big
deal you lose some data you lose privacy
they reset your credit card and password
if you're talking about killing everyone
the standard should be somewhat higher
in my opinion yeah and so I guess it
comes down to fundamentally a moral qu
question about what level of risk makes
sense and but but that's I mean what
you're what you're doing in in the book
and in in your work in general as I see
it is is more setting up proofs about
what we can't have and so you you have
you have a separate discussions of the
moral questions but but we can separate
those and we can talk about whether the
proofs hold and then whether what we
should do in the moral domain or with
the question of what level of risk we're
we're interested in running here just on
a personal level you're not interested
in in running basically a 1% risk or you
know as 0.1% risk or anything like that
so even if I was I don't think I have a
right to make that decision for 8
billion other humans they cannot consent
to it because as I said the system is
unpredictable un explainable so they
cannot give you a meaningful consent
they don't know what they consenting to
so this is very unethical you would
never be allowed in any other scientific
domain to run experiment on other humans
who cannot provide meaningful consent
especially if the outcome could be
complete
extermination and so the one issue is
also that we we can't we can't with
Precision say what the probability of of
an AI catastrophe is so we we hear the
the heads of the major AI corporations
talking about maybe 10% or 20% I've
heard academics that are interested in
this domain say the same number but one
result of AI being unpredictable or
unexplainable is that we can't get a a
precise number of the risk of Extinction
so these are of course subjective
probabilities but we can't nail down any
yeah we can't na nail down any
probability of of
catastrophe absolutely we can't make
precise predictions and even worse if
you look at other predictions in this
domain for example how soon before AGI I
think it changed by orders of magnitude
in the last year so what good are those
predictions to begin with next accident
next uh paper will completely change
them although with language models in
particular we see these scaling laws
where capabilities increase as a
function of of training data and and
compute usage so we can say something
about which capabilities will arise in
the next model and that might be good
enough for some policy policy
applications or some security measures
I'm not sure we can say what
capabilities will arise we're saying it
will be more capable but we don't have
precise predictive power and exactly GPT
5 will have the following I don't think
anyone makes that claim no that's true
but we might say something about for
example the length of of a text output
that can be produced at a certain level
given given certain data given certain
compute and so that that is somewhat of
a prediction of of the capabilities of
the models I'm just thinking if if we
accept your conclusions here that we
can't predict AI with any with any
interesting level of certainty what do
we have then right we we must kind of
work with what we have and and maybe the
scaling laws are the least bad
predictive tool we have well we can work
with what we have literally we have a
model which has so much potential which
hasn't been integrated with the economy
has not been fully understood or explore
it we can spend the next 30 Years is
exploring existing model and growing
Economy based on that integrating it
with existing infrastructure there is no
need to have gpt7 next year like that's
not a requirement for anything not
economic growth not scientific progress
it's just kind of a very misguided
competition towards possible
Annihilation do you think the current
scaling laws we have now will hold as AI
become more agent likee so will will the
scaling laws we have for more tool like
AIS also hold for more agent like AIS
it's likely I mean if it's a byproduct
of having enough compute sufficient
number of neurons to model the world I
would expect something similar I'm not
sure we have enough data natural data to
continue scaling maybe artificial data
will be good enough maybe not it's still
being experimentally determined but as
long as we have enough computer and
enough to train on yeah it will keep
getting more capable yeah I think the
the synthetic data might be a big un
uncertainty or big open question about
whether if that can work we can continue
scaling but if that doesn't work we've B
we're basically using the entire
internet already and so I don't of
course I don't know about what the labs
have or the corporations have as as
proprietary data sets that they might
train on but do do you think AI progress
hinges on whether synthetic data can
work it could be a bottleneck but it
seems like we can generate very good
synthetic data we can create simulations
of our civilization we can have
self-play type data creation where the
agents just compete in the domain we
care about until like we saw with go for
example they they are at very good level
of performance compared to humans so I
don't think it's a permanent problem but
it may slow down things for a little
while there's been a lot of effort into
trying to determine when we might get
and AGI so artificial general
intelligence and and do do you think do
you think we should spend more resources
trying to trying to predict this year or
is it is it interesting knowledge is it
is it something that do we gain
something that's useful for the actions
we take by trying to get better models
of of when we we we get to AI
information is always useful but I'm not
sure whatever it's two years or five
years makes any significant difference
especially if a problem is not solvable
to begin with so uh I person personally
don't make significant changes based on
this prediction I seen top CEOs say okay
we're two years away from AGI SE people
say F at no point did that somehow
impact what I'm doing or concentrating
on these as you mentioned before these
these predictions of when we get AGI
have kind of Fallen quite rapidly
recently and so maybe maybe just five
years ago it was more common to hear 30
years or 20 years whereas now it's more
common to hear maybe five years maybe
both of us and the listener maybe also
we're in in a bubble but I don't know
what what do you have a sense of of
people outside the the kind of AI bubble
what do they what do they see here what
do they predict so there are degrees of
this outsideness from the bubble there
are those who are so outside they don't
even know what we are talking about they
have no experience with AI or maybe even
computers and internet those who are a
little closer they they see it as okay
it's an excellent tool it's going to
help us you know with marketing efforts
for a startup or something but they
don't see it as complete Game Cher and
definitely very very few people
understand what happens then we hit full
human capability and Beyond and then I
tell them okay it could be two years I'm
not saying it is two years but it very
well could be there is just cognitive
dis announce they don't understand so
the follow-up questions are like
completely irrelevant to the
consequences you would expect from that
do you think un unpredictability scales
with intelligence so as so a system is
less predictable as it becomes more
intelligent uh do the lower level
intelligence yes so it's much harder to
predict something you know 10 times
smarter than you than five smart well
now we we're talking about the the the
intelligence of the Observer but I was
just thinking that at a certain level of
of of intelligence a very low level say
say a an AI that can play checkers or
something right that that seems almost
fully predictable and so where does it
break why what is it is is there a a
threshold that's that's reached or what
is it that makes more advanced AI
unpredictable so it could be even a
narrow domain so a game like chess or go
as I said if it's an opponent who's
playing better than you you're not going
to predict it even if it's completely
stupid and every other domain cannot
drive cars or anything uh in general I
would guess the generality is a big big
thres hold big jump because you're
switching from predicting in one or a
few domains to every conceivable domain
including invention of new domains and
that's that's hard to predict and do you
think that generality is is this kind of
step that's reached to do do you think
for example that the the gpts are are
General in the sense you mentioned there
because of course there are domains in
which gpts can't operate so so there is
a chapter in a book about the difference
between human level and aggi and you can
talk about different degrees of
generality as well so you can have a
system which is General in let's say
five domains it's General within those
humans may be General in the domain of
human expertise which could be hundreds
of domains but we are not Universal we
don't have certain capabilities animals
have so you can talk about as the system
gets more General it becomes harder and
harder to predict it harder and harder
to compete with it gpts large language
models definitely General but not
Universal they don't have generality
there are many domains in which they
fail miserably but the number of domains
in which they are highly competent keeps
increasing and that is something we can
predict with scalability loss yeah so
actually say say a bit more about this
is something I wanted to ask you about
why are humans not agis because I think
there's a maybe a tendency to conflate
AGI artificial general intelligence with
human level intelligence so so why are
these two not the same so there are
certain things we cannot do which
already computer we have today are
capable of doing for example there are
some interesting uh pattern recognition
things where you can look at someone's
x-ray or retinal skin and know things
about their race gender things which a
human doctor has no idea how you get
there there are other examples I use in
a paper where basically yes there is
pattern recognition in a type where you
can take my voice and synthesize a face
from it uh things which are just beyond
human capabilities I'm not talking just
like adding large numbers as a
calculator yeah that's outside of human
domain but it's not interesting there
are things computers can do which we
just don't have capability of
accomplishing are humans more General
than than current AIS do we have a way
of measuring generality I I would say we
are still more General there are things
we can do that gpts are not helpful with
that's why I still do my own research
that's why you know you interviewing me
and not a GPT model but in many domains
they are superior to me they are much
better in so many things they speak
hundreds of languages I don't speak they
can produce now music and all these
musical instruments that they don't play
so we are no longer directly comparable
in terms of okay we are superior in all
those it's more like it has a subset of
50 domains it's better at and I have a
subset of 10 domains I'm still keeping
as my dominant space it is actually an
interesting experience to to chat with
the language model and realize that
these models have kind of basic
competency across an extremely broad uh
number of domains and so you can try to
to talk to it about your favorite
subject and it'll it'll be it'll be
pretty good you'll be able to to spot
some flaws on his reasoning and some
facts that are missing but then you
think you know this holds for all
domains it can U discuss Roman history
as well as engineering on Mars at an
equal level probably depending on what's
in the training data but yeah so it's it
is surprisingly General but perhaps it
it makes sense to say that humans are
still more General I I'm asking because
we don't have a formal measure of
generality right we don't have anything
that's that can measure it in a formal
sense that's right we don't and we kind
of try to talk about humans okay those
are geniuses those are not Geniuses they
can pick up new domains very quickly
they can compete with other humans much
better but yeah it's not trivial where
you can say like this is g74 this is G20
it would be great to develop this type
of measurements and tests but it's very
timec consuming we don't have a complete
list of domains and we keep inventing
new domains and intersections of domains
are always interesting so it's a big
open problem kind of part of what makes
this so difficult and gives you a hint
for why maybe it's not easy to test for
everything and predict everything and
explain all possibilities
yeah why why are you making this point
that that humans are not agis is it
because is because we we are then to
realize that AGI will not be like humans
do do you think that is that is that the
the kind of confusion you're trying to
to solve so there is a lot of redefining
of terms I think lately I hear people
talk about AGI in terms which used to be
reserved for super intelligence that's
even more confusing and historically we
had human level used interchangeably
with AGI and I'm just pointing out I
mean for most conversations that's what
we have in mind but they are not the
same they are not equal and I think
there is an infinite subset of domains
which are not included in human
capabilities which even standard AGI
will be able to achieve and then Super
intelligence is just like yeah super
capable in all of those I I was asking
because one standard Point I've heard a
bunch of time is that you know we we
shouldn't be scared of of of AI we
shouldn't be worried about the effects
of AI because we already have 8 billion
agis on the planet and so maybe maybe at
one point of distinguishing between AGI
and human level intelligence or human
intelligence is to say that agis will
not be like humans and they may not
integrate into the economy just as a
person would and be kind of non
problematic in that sense absolutely
that that's part of it and the second
part is it will have those magical
capabilities
in things we as humans don't have any
comprehension of but it will be able to
do that if AI is unpredictable and does
it also mean that the effects of AGI or
or AI are unpredictable so so we can't
say for example what will happen in the
economy at a certain level of artificial
intelligence well in general even if we
could predict what AI will do we don't
know how that will impact the world so a
lot of times we know that this
technology is coming but what people
actually do with it how they use it is
so Dynamic and depends on us being able
to predict 8 billion humans and their
preferences so yeah definitely you have
multiple degrees of unpredictability but
I'm just limiting my research to
decisions made by AI both as a final
decision and intermediate decisions to
get there yeah but you seem pretty
worried about disempowerment or loss of
control to to Ai and and isn't that a a
kind of distinct prediction about the
future effects of AI it's a general
prediction about what will happen but I
don't know what that means does that
mean we're just kind of useless and have
nothing to contribute does it mean it
kills everyone does it mean it's keeping
us alive and tortures us indefinitely
it's not the same uncontrollability yeah
yeah so so there are multiple way ways
that we could fail to get a good future
with with AI exactly unexplainable is
another point you talk about there's a
there's a whole research field dedicated
to trying to interpret models so
interpretability research uh more
specifically mechanistic
interpretability research is this is
this just doomed to fail in that we
can't explain AI if if we have some
formal results saying that that AI is is
unexplainable so all those results are
of course connected you can find one
realiz in another they are complimentary
with explainability you basically have
the situation where yeah we can know
what this specific neuron gets triggered
by when it fires what it does but if you
have a large enough model it's not
surveyable you as a human don't have
enough time resources memory to fully
comprehend the model as a whole you can
be an expert in this like left neuron
and someone at MIT does the right neuron
and like we kind of have some
understanding of parts of it but no one
has complete understanding of a whole
the only explanation which is true is
the model itself
now you can make simplifications like
lossy compression you can say well top
10 reasons this happened is this that's
possible we can do that but that hides a
lot of information if decision was made
with you know a thousand weights uh
trillion neurons and you are given top
10 reasons something is lost in that
explanation it may be good enough for
many things it's not good enough to
guarantee perfect safety for a system
which makes thousands of decisions every
second is isn't it the case that modern
science for example is not explainable
in the same sense if if we have taken
your your terms we have a person at MIT
studying one aspect of modern science
but no one has the full picture but
modern science seems to work fine even
though it's it's unexplainable in the
sense that you know the the analogy of
course between science and and the model
it's a great question so think about
having a scientist who actually has all
this knowledge a single scientist with
phds and all this disciplines read all
the papers can we compete with that
scientist can they come up with things
at a border of all these disciplines we
would never consider and that's what I'm
talking about we would not be
competitive we would not understand how
we're producing this completely magical
technology and producing it so quickly
so you describe a tradeoff between the
accuracy of an explanation for a
decision or behavior that an AI is
implementing and then our ability to
understand that explanation so that
perhaps explain this this trade-off
between accuracy and our comprehension
of the explanation so I kind of started
it with this either you get a full model
and you cannot comprehend it it's too
large it's not surveyable or you get a
simplified dumb down explanation kind of
what we do with children so a children a
child may ask you where do kids come
from and you like start thinking oh God
do I want to explain all biology they
not going to get or oh we bought you in
a store a store brought you so you're
getting this simplified just so
explanation which is not accurate and
that's the tradeoff we are limited in
what we can comprehend it's not
something about humans every machine at
every level has upper limit on what it
can comprehend maybe do just to simple
memory size limitations maybe it's the
complexity we can comprehend so we know
we from studying psychology we know
there are strong upper limits and human
capabilities so at some point for any
human agent or any AI there is going to
be another agent which is so large so
more so much more complex that there
will be limits to what can be understood
yeah and so if we take an example maybe
say that in the future we have some AI
investment advisor that tells us oh you
should invest in these 17 companies and
you ask you kind of ask the model ask
the AI why is that and an accurate
explanation would involve a thousand
factors that that would take weeks to to
to explain and so you can only get the
kind of dumb down version from that
model and that creates a kind of a a
non-secure situation exactly you don't
understand what's happening how it's
happening and it's hard to debug things
like that and at some point you kind of
give up all together you treat it as an
oracle you goes well AI was right the
last 20 times I still don't understand
what it's doing but I'm winning so let's
just switch completely to trusting this
model we're not even going to try to
understand how it works and that's where
it's like okay I waited to weeks now we
strike so kind of like a general version
of how we treat chess computers now
where they will make some move that
turns out 17 moves ahead to be the right
move but we can't understand why and we
and it doesn't play chess like humans
play chess and yeah we can imagine how
that would be you know if it's if it's
just a game and it's limited to chess
that's fine but if it's make an
investment decision decisions or making
political decisions that's perhaps or it
is more more consequential I guess the
big question there is then could we use
AI to understand AI so we are not fast
enough we don't have enough memory but
maybe we can have an AI interpretability
researcher help us uh do this work is
that a possibility so we definitely have
awesome tools and they're helpful in
many things but if you cannot fully
debug and comprehend Model A is model A1
A2 A3 all the way to super intelligent
God going to simplify to where now you
get it you just have more degrees of
oracles more degrees of trust more
opportunities for miscommunication for
bugs to be introduced and covered so it
seems like it's it's a way to kind of
hide this problem away in complexity
it's a plan that's been mentioned a
bunch of times over the last decades to
to we have some some problem with AI and
we saw that problem with AI couldn't if
say we optimize very hard for having an
agent that's that's just just good at
interpretability research only why
couldn't it work to have that agent
interpret a weaker agent so now we we
are our our best resources and our our
you know our biggest model is the
interpretability model and our weaker
model that we're that we're interested
in finding out what it's doing why it's
doing it before we deploy you know we
haven't spent as much money on that one
so imagine imagine a situation where we
where we're spending 10x more research
money and re and resources in General on
The Interpreter model would that work so
it seems like what we do in practice is
we use a more powerful model to explain
a weaker model so they use GPT 4 to
explain gpt2 that's a little too late at
that point if you're trying to establish
how gpt2 works and you need it's catch22
I need a controlled super intelligence
to help me develop simple AGI yeah if
you had access to it you can certainly
use it but you don't get it until you
already have a controlled safe verified
debugged system and that's what I'm
saying you're not getting with the
resources with we're working with how do
you think autonomy or agentic or agency
scale with intelligence so so as models
become more capable do they also become
more autonomous or agent like I I think
so and I think the important thing would
be so you can have a super intelligence
which is still kind of narrow it's super
intelligent in 10,000 domains but not
everything the ultimate super
intelligence in my opinion would be the
one which has no boundaries it can
reexamine its own code including its own
terminal goals it can look at the goals
and see what is the origin of his goal
was this something I derive from first
principles from physics from running
experiments or is this something this
guy just typed in because you know he
was having fun if there is no reason for
this goal then and it's a bug in a
system and you debias your system just
like humans frequently discover okay all
this religious teaching I was brought up
with it's not based on anything
verifiable I should probably find a
different set of beliefs I I think there
is a certain level of capability where
an AI system is able to debug its own
terminal goals which is not a standard
belief people usually think it's given
orthagonal thesis holds at all levels
and as long as you have that goal you'll
protect it with your current values
because that's your current goal but I
think we'll hit a point where yeah it
will reevaluate every part of its own
source code do you think we are trying
to avoid that do you think we are the
way we're developing AI now is trying to
avoid AI changing their terminal
goals well in theory we would like
stability but the way we develop AIS
right now we just see what works and put
more resources into anything that
remotely gives us more capabilities
it's the worst way possible what about
controllability how does that scale with
capability does does a system become
more uncontrollable when it becomes more
capable almost by definition yeah if you
are controlling it it has no
Independence it has very limited domain
specific range of possibilities as it
becomes more capable it can come up with
novel things unpredicted I could not
predict them so I didn't test for them I
don't have a rule for them so so it's
more independent and I have very little
control over what it's going to do and
the problems we're interested in solving
in in science for example we want to
cure cancer we we're not going to solve
those problems by having a model that's
very constrained but but good in narrow
domains where we are kind of every step
along the way we are directing it it
makes a suggestion I want to spend $10
million on This research Direction you
say yes that's VI not a viable way to
for future AI to to function well
actually surprisingly I think synthetic
biology is very narrow if you noticed
with the protein folding with a very
narrow system works beautifully and has
absolutely no knowledge of any other
domain so I think understanding human
DNA explaining how that works and fixing
things like the cycle runs infinite
reset this Loop to not have cancerous
growth is actually quite trivial for
something which can hold the whole
genome in its memory and run you know
sufficient number of simulations and
experiments so I think we can get most
of the benefits we care about like cure
for diseases and maybe even immortality
without having to create Universal Super
intelligence yeah so you look at a
number of disciplines and and find clues
that AI can't be controlled in these
disciplines maybe you can sketch some of
some of the evidence from from these
disciplines as to why AI is
uncontrollable so I kind of suspected
that if I just say it you know like you
can't do it you can't create
indefinitely controlled super
intelligence people would be like who
the hell are you why should we would
trust you so I directly quote from
hundreds of different top Scholars top
papers different disciplines where every
aspect of it whatever it's political
science economics psychology there are
well-known impossibility results and we
have additional papers specifically
surveying those results the title of a
book gives you three but there are
hundreds of them for all those things we
want to do here we know it's impossible
in certain cases we cannot all agree on
many things there are voting limits we
cannot kind of distill specific values
and moral and ethical codes we all agree
on and again I suggest the best thing
here is to read the book it literally
gives you quotes you can check don't
take my word for it verify for yourself
and I don't think explicitly many people
agree no one says you're wrong we can
definitely control super intelligence
here's why here is the Prototype it
scales with compute we definitely have
it I just that's not a thing no one
actually has a solution no one claims
that they have a solution it's really
bizarre that that's not a default
state-of-the-art belief in the field
it's actually a minority view maybe it's
not a default view because it seems so
negative about our future or our it
seems like a it seems like a real Downer
if we can't control these systems but
we're still developing them I think
maybe people would be looking for what's
the takeaway when we have all of these
impossibility results what then what
should we then do should we just sit and
and and wait until things go wrong or
what's maybe it seems disempowering to
to be told that you can solve a certain
problem well I I think it's very good
thing you know that you are very capable
you are the smartest thing around and
you have those awesome tools to help you
with as I said synthetic biology
economics we can get cures we can get
immortality we can get wealth we can get
free labor why do we have to create
Godlike super intelligence we don't
control to see what happens let's take a
few decades really enjoy this really get
all the benefits out maybe later we'll
know something we don't know right now
but I I don't think it's a very
pessimistic negative concept yes you
cannot indefinitely control super
intelligent beings why would you think
you can do you worry that so so these
these results are are kind of
theoretical and and fundamental your
you're drawing from from kind of very
very basic or or fundamental results in
in a variety of disciplines do worry
that that when you look at the empirical
reality that that kind of the even
though you have the formal results
reality functions a bit differently or
maybe the formal result doesn't capture
exactly the phenomenon you were trying
to formalize that that's that's happened
a bunch of times in
history that's really the case obviously
theory and practice are not the same but
practice is harder
you can say that yeah in the I can build
a skyscraper with a thousand floors but
in reality it's hard those things can
collapse so I think it's harder to do in
practice not easier and what we see
empirically right now I think supports
my findings very strongly that's very
interesting what are these empirical
things we see that support your findings
so empirically we know that all the
socalled safe models which are publicly
released jail broken all the time we
bypassed all of those limitations if
there is a limitation this system can
never print the following we find a way
to rephrase it where the system prints
the following and that's again without
access to the source code this is still
controlled API call where they can
quickly shut you down in monitor the
moment this leaks the moment you have
access to weights all those safety
things go out the window we have a huge
push right now in AI Community for open-
sourcing those models to be begin with
so I I can't even think how to make it
less safe if I wanted to give it access
to Internet open source it give it to
every human they hit every check mark
for making the most unsafe AI possible
all of our kind of critical it
infrastructure is vulnerable so cyber
secur is you have to continually invest
in cyber security just to just to not be
hacked just to not lose access to data
all of these things but the systems are
still kind of functioning okayish could
it be the case that we kind of like we
kind of model through and we reduce the
probabilities the probability of of
catastrophe along the way and although
we don't get to to 100% certainty that
that these systems won't fail we are
satisfied with it's kind of like a
middle position where we we have some
risk but we've driven the risk down to
an acceptable level right and that can
happen for GPT 5 and it'd be awesome if
we stopped there and said hey see it's
not so bad let's enjoy this but we'll
immediately do six seven eight so we'll
always have a second third fourth chance
to fail miserably and if there is only
1% that it ends very poorly well you see
how quickly we are getting to that
probabilistic resource we keep trying we
keep making this a Perpetual
impossibility so maybe you can do okay
with existing model but can you promise
the same for all future models which
will keep releasing faster and faster
what about Sim imulation this is
something you also discussed where we
might be able to put an an AI we're
we're thinking of of deploying into a
simulated environment and seeing what it
does this is a this is extremely
difficult technical task but maybe that
that could work we we we observe it for
a while and see how it acts and if we
don't like how it acts then we then we
go back to the drawing board and and
Tinker with the model until it acts
different so so that's how we run
experiments right we have test
environment we run the model we'll see
what happens we make modifications but
of course if it's smart enough at
certain point a it knows you are testing
it it's a test environment and so it can
delay its actual decisions sufficiently
it can hide its thinking there's a
separate paper on how to escape from a
simulation how to hack the simulation so
it will probably succeed if it wanted to
in breaking out of this virtual
environment I've I've read a bunch of
papers on Deception but I I I always
struggle with understanding how the
deceptive imput FSE you could call it
arises to begin with if you're TR
training on a on a certain objective it
seems difficult for me to understand how
the AI would become deceptive have you
ever been a child I have indeed been a
child have you tried deceiving your
parents about your actions I probably
have yes yeah so it's the same exact
thing and there is actually one argument
ahead for why things may be not so bad
is that AI will want to deceive us and
accumulate more resources to increase
the differential in power and so maybe
it is already very capable it is trying
to destroy us but it will take the next
10 20 years to build up more
infrastructure for itself so that's good
for us we're getting another 20 years so
that's essentially the decision here I'm
going to have more time to accumulate
more striking power but everyone
benefits for those 20 years humans are
going to be very happy with me they're
not going to shut me down I don't think
that's very comforting to be to people
unfortunately 20 years is better than
two years
true true okay you discuss unverifiable
of AI but before we get to why AI can't
be verified I want you to talk a bit
about the concept of the verifier in
general why is this an interesting
theoretical concept and how could it be
useful if we could get efficient
verifier so in mathematics we have very
strong proof Theory we study proof as
mathematical objects but we do much less
with verifiers we do less with that in
physics we do less with it in computer
science in physics we don't even agree
on what this concept of agent Observer
is supposedly only conscious humans can
collapse wave function Maybe not maybe
instruments we don't know in mathematics
we have a few different types of
verifiers we have humans as individuals
so this mathematician verified this
proof we have mathematical Community
most mathematicians agreed that one
through peer review we now have software
which does formal verification it goes
through the code but all of it collapses
who verifies the verifier you have
relativistic proofs with respect to this
mathematician this is true maybe this
mathematician reads it and they find a
bug in it there is strong history of
proofs which stood the test of time been
considered through for 100 years later
we discover in B in software we know
there are bugs in almost all software
and we keep discovering it late years
later piece of Unix kernel which has
been used for 30 years we we now know
there is a back door things of that
nature so empirically and theoretically
we know that you cannot have
100% correct proofs or software you can
make it arbitrarily close to perfect
with more resources you increase the
number of verifiers you increase methods
by which you verify but you never get to
100% so that's just something to keep in
mind if again you have a system which is
huge keeps self-improving self-modifying
Works in novel domains and makes
thousands millions of decisions every
second it's not insane to think it's
going to make one mistake every 10
minutes which could be enough is it just
me that thinks for some reason that we
have error free code in these critical
systems in in the International Space
Station or in nuclear systems that we
have code that is that is verified to
function correctly with respect to that
verifier who verified that verifier Some
Humans so the proof is that Bob thinks
it's true we can get obviously for
shorter segments of code we can almost
be sure that 2 plus 2 is four without
fail yes but then you keep scaling it
this probability is reduced until at
some point it becomes very small and now
again we don't stop we don't have static
software we have a system which is
dynamically learning changing rewriting
code indefinitely it's a perpetual
motion problem we're trying to solve we
know in physics you cannot create
perpetual motion device but in AI in
computer science we're saying we can
create Perpetual safety device which
will always guarantee that the new
iteration is just as safe and so the
reason why AI can't be verified or it's
unverifiable is because AI could itself
be a verifier and so you would run into
an infinite regress problem is that the
correct way to
that's one way of looking at it you you
have an infinite regress what are you
verifying with respect to at some point
you have to stop you can say this was
verified with this piece of software
great who verified it this other piece
of software and what about that one well
this team of Engineers at Google so at
the end the whole thing rests on five
humans maybe they right maybe not who
verified brains of those humans could
but could could you verify formally
speaking the the parts of say a neural
network that aren't themselves a verify
is that possible you you can do a lot
you can do Hardware we keep discovering
bugs and CPUs years after deployment so
it's possible that there are back doors
in those there are also theoretical
results showing that you can introduce
hidden back doors into machine learning
models which are not detectable so you
can verify its performance in a normal
environment but if there is a trigger it
changes behavior of a system and you
cannot detect that those are proven
results so we have good verification
tools they are super useful in many
domains they work great for narrow AI
systems controlling space flight and
nuclear reactors but they don't scale to
General self-improving recursively
modifying software operating in new
domains and I don't think anyone claims
that we know how to verify that and that
really is I guess your your main point
then that the the reason why we have a
bunch of code out there with arrows in
it Arrow and and we the world hasn't
collapsed yet is because we don't have a
very smart agent out there with perhaps
different goals than we have trying to
exploit all of these eras right the
exploits for those are usually how do I
get your Bitcoin how do I get your
credit card so this is nasty but no one
dies from it right like it's not a big
deal you get a new credit card this is
very different if you have an adversary
who's trying to take over and maybe
destroy you then it becomes much more
significant and I guess this is a very
classic question but it's I think it's
worth asking why is it that the AI
develops goals that are different from
from our goals why is it that it's not
aligned by default aligned by default
let me let me let me make and I'm not
saying I believe in this case but let me
make the case for for aligned by default
you are training on a data set of all of
human preferences and beliefs and so you
would get something humanlike that's one
argument and you have you're deploying
these systems Within economy and a
capitalistic system and and a you know a
regulated market that's that's also
controlled by human preferences and so
the the intelligence would have to to
abide by certain so say for ex if you if
you deploy a system that's that's on
aligned and it harms the users well then
the company loses money and then it
shuts down why can't that work why can't
we get kind of stumble and model our way
through in a way where we we have
something that's that's pretty aligned
in the imperfect sense sense that
companies today are aligned to to
people's interests so I certainly heard
this question before and there is like
30 different angles to attack it we'll
start with the basics so we are not
aligned as humans there is 8 billion of
us we don't agree on anything we don't
have common goals we don't have like
some things we agree on like room
temperature within a certain range maybe
but for all the important things if you
take individual human and give them
Absolute Power they start totally
abusing the other bilon humans so we are
only limited by our capabilities the
moment we are super capable Godlike we
remove all this ethical baggage and we
start abusing people so assuming that
humans are safe and just creating
artificial human will get us to safety
is already a mistake now let's look at
other aspects integration with Society
through legal aspects through economy
you have a system you cannot punish our
legal system is based on you will go to
prison if you do this how do you you do
it with software what are you going to
do put it in a separate hard drive
delete it like it has a billion copies
of its agood everywhere so the legal
system does not apply economic system
will give you money well if a system can
directly produce Free Labor it can earn
money it can hack crypto exchanges it
can generate wealth at the level if that
was what it tried to do now we're
already talking about a pretty Advanced
and Powerful system what about the in
the intermediate term where we have so
we have G 5 for example G gbt 5 is
controlled by open AI for now right it's
controlled by the economic factors
whether open AI can make a profit
deploying the system it's it's it's
under you know us legal jurisdiction so
the way I'm I'm imagining that we might
model through is is by the intermediate
AI system being controlled and then we
don't just jump straight to the to the
kind of super intelligent or highly
Advanced system that that is that is
fully kind of independent of human
institutions yeah but we don't know what
GPT 5 is going to be it could be AI in
fact that's what the heads of those labs
literally are telling us two years that
means GPT 5 so I think we kind of first
train the model and then learn how
capable it is so saying that we're going
to stop well before AGI is hard because
we have not defined the term we don't
have a test for it and we don't know
what it's capable of until we train it
and test it for months and months okay
you have a you have a section on cyber
security versus or a discussion of
comparing cyber security to AI safety
and that that was that was quite
interesting to me it's I was thinking
whether cyber security is an is an
indirect route to AI safety so if you're
if you're working if you're improving
cyber security at the AI corporations or
maybe at at in governmental
organizations is that a way to to kind
of Harden our societal uh infrastructure
against attacks from AI so historically
I thought it was very important you
would protect the code from being
accessed by malevolent actors but again
we we're going towards open source so
all those things we worked on a decade
ago boxing of AI better encryption
techniques we don't seem to be utilizing
them in our models we kind of bypassing
the things which actually we know they
work even part-time but at least they
they give us something so I don't think
it's going to make a huge difference in
that the chapter is mostly about
explaining the difference between what
happens then cyber security fails versus
what happens then your AGI safety fails
and people have a hard time
understanding the difference so in one
case again the same example I keep
pushing on you you reset your credit
card it's annoying it's unpleasant you
have to retype the number in the other
case you that I guess one response from
the from the pro open source side is to
say that we we will have a bunch of open
s ource based models defend us against
attacks so we so this is a bit of the
same thought of as having an AI help us
interpret another AI here we have here
we use AI defensively to defend our
systems and the reasoning goes that
because because say a corporation will
have more resources to spend on
defensive AI than an attacker will have
to to attack that that Corporation the
corporations will tend to win and so
Society will will keep on kind of
functioning so that kind of assumes that
opensource AI is friendly and nice why
is that assumption made they're
uncontrollable all of them cannot be
controlled so whatever it's a good guy
or bad guy who creates it is irrelevant
if you somehow convince me that yes they
made them friendly because they open
source now you have a war between super
intelligent AIS and we just collateral
damage none of it sounds good for now
for example meta's open source models
are not extremely Advanced they are not
super intelligences
and they seem pretty much under human
control to me you keep switching kind of
you keep saying AI but then I talk about
superintelligence you go back to like
this spell checker yes today it's
wonderful open source software is great
it competes really well with Microsoft
yes all of that is true the moment
you're switching to Advanced it's just
more danger less control you now have
malevolent payload added by terrorists
crazy Psychopaths so it seems like a
strictly bad thing to open source how
how quickly do you think we we launch
into the to to the super intelligence
kind of era is how how how quickly do
you see that that change occurring
because maybe maybe that's that's why I
keep switching back and forth between
the systems because I'm I may see it a
bit more of a gradual development tell
me about your your kind of a yeah
timelines here sure so we started with
that in fact I don't have any Insider
knowledge so I trust people running
those laps they said two years to AGI I
believe them if they're wrong in it's
four years makes no difference it's the
same very short amount of time it is not
decades it is not hundreds of years the
only hope I told you is if a system
decides to not strike to accumulate
strategic Advantage then we have decades
maybe more but that's a gamble I
wouldn't bet on that so actually I have
a whole section of questions prepared
about trying to build AI that is
humanlike and you just a while ago you
made comment saying that there's not
actually a Safe Way Forward because even
humans aren't aligned with the interests
of humanity at large but is it perhaps
safer safer than just going to straight
towards kind of Sho like super
intelligence what what AI developed to
be humanlike be easier to control it may
be easier for us to understand it may
have more of bias towards somehow human
generated preferences but I don't think
it's a guarantee of safety a while ago
we had a paper about whom to upload
first so you have this upload capability
who is this Mother Teresa we're going to
upload first and turns out she's an evil
monster who tortures people so it's very
hard to find someone who's not or even
harder to find someone who will not
become that including myself given that
level of power that level of resources I
don't think anyone will withstand that
set of opportunities great power corrupt
absolutely that's literally what happens
I want to kind of try a bunch of of
approaches here see see what what you
what you think of them these are all
these are all under building AI that is
humanlike the analogy again if if we go
back to chess there there's a guy
there's a researcher developing a chess
program or chess software that plays
more like a human and in that and that
that is that's supposed to be more
enjoyable because when you play against
the computer it you don't understand the
moves it's it's making it feels alien to
you and so maybe we could do the same
across a bunch of domains where we're
trying to develop AI in a way that mimic
Humanity or or or a human way of
thinking and of if we set aside I
understand that your your timelines are
perhaps quite short and this is not this
would take Decades of research maybe but
just you know bear with me while we kind
of go through this you have this thought
of this concept of artificial stupidity
where we we kind of degrade AI
capabilities in in in in certain ways
and is this mostly about limiting the
training data so just not including
advanced concepts that would that would
make an AI highly capable or how how do
you make artificial stupidity so it was
an idea to limit kind of Hardware
resources the system has to exactly the
levels of what we expect on average
human to be from psychology research so
in memory shortterm memory we know
humans are kind of seven units plus or
minus two so AI has almost infinite
memory that seems like an unfair
Advantage let's make a servants have the
same level of memory accessible to them
so just kind of hardcoded this is for
not super intelligent system capable of
rewriting its own code this is like the
current assistant models so they're not
too smart around us and we talk about
other things in terms of speed of
reaction mathematical capabilities so
basically to pass a tting test you don't
have to be smarter you have to be
humanlike but we don't have a formal
discipline of what are those upper
limits for humans so we try to extract
this information from different
psychology papers and give it as a set
of limits for creating an AI which is
very likely to pass a touring test at
least in the sense that it's not
appearing to be Godlike super
intelligent it's a it's a very funny
Point actually where you would fail a
tur test almost immediately if if you if
you're asked say I'm the AI and you ask
me you know how tall is the Eiffel Tower
and I answer precisely it is a 3 point
or
34.7 978 meters taller so then it's then
it's just over so you would have to
include include some some limited
capability in order to fake being human
exactly and same with like mathematical
questions multiplying two numbers
anything like that is thally going to
give it away if you don't have limits
but what about so that's that's the
hardware or the kind of processing speed
or memory what about limiting training
data is is that isn't that a way of kind
of hamstringing the model to be more
human but also more safe we we didn't
explicitly look at that because it's so
hard to find restricted data sets which
don't mention certain topics like it'd
be great to have data set of human
knowledge minus all the violence but
it's just not something out there if it
was accessible I would think it'd be
great to experiment with in kind of same
way it's not a universal general
intelligence subdomain restricted that
would be interesting result does it get
us infinite safety over all iterations
no but it's a cute marketing gimmick but
could it be more than a marketing
gimmick could it be an actual
interesting safety intervention if you
if you spend a bunch of resources and
time creating these data sets that do
not include information on synthesizing
a new virus or hacking or all of these
things yeah is that a viable path
forward it could be interest to have
those they would be hard to produce
cleaning data is hard because there is
so much information smuggled in and
again the problem is we don't restrict
the models they have access to Internet
with all the data they're open source so
the first teenager to get it will
immediately give it full access so it's
like we're fighting against ourselves we
have this good idea and then we're
saying we're not even going to try doing
it da we we talk more about the the
synthesizing a virus example do do you
think that say we have an AI that that
doesn't include that's that's trained on
a data set that doesn't include kind of
explicit information about how to do
this in practice or maybe maybe not any
information about viruses at all but it
has general knowledge of chemistry and
now we're and imagine further that we're
talking about a more advanced model so
maybe more advanced dpd5 do you think
that that such an AI could come to
understand viruses or discover viruses
within its own kind of epistemology from
looking at General chemistry knowled or
General Physics knowledge I would guess
that sufficiently smart agent can derive
everything from first principle so if
you give it physics models ability to
run at least thought experiments it
would arrive at everything else as long
as it depends on physics do do you think
that's physically possible because you
just you you can't like you can't
predict the economy by looking at the
Motions of particles or something like
it's just computationally interactable I
think that's a different question you're
saying now will it have enough compute
to do that but I think you can run
simulations which aggregate from level
of atoms to molecules to you know cells
and you can probably get good partial
results we don't run models at the level
of bits right our models at the level of
Sims you so at some point you build up
enough layers where your experiments are
directly comparable to the world you're
trying to simulate how strong are these
kind of limits that are imposed by
computational resources in general is
that maybe a reason for for hope that
that AI will remain non-dangerous
because maybe because they they need a
lot of computational resources to even
function or maybe because they can't uh
you can't get extreme intelligence with
with the computers we have it seems that
once we have a model we quickly find
ways to optimize it in terms of size in
terms of required comput so there's
probably very little need for energy for
matter we see certain animals like birds
crows have tiniest of brains highly
dense neural structure as smart as human
children so there are probably other
models which are much more efficient and
those systems are very good at finding
resources we have again all this compute
we're buying for them at research Labs
but also look at the crypto economy what
is the size of a Bitcoin verification
Network right now it's the greatest
supercomputer in the world I'm sure
there is a way to somehow use that to to
do your hidden computation on the on the
other side you could say what are the
upper limits of what we could create so
so if you if you had kind of matter
optimized for intelligence what would
that look like have have you looked into
computronium I think it's called or just
like what are the what are the upper
limits here so the upper limit would be
speed of light I'm guessing unless that
doesn't hold anymore the communication
between different parts of that agent
would be a limiting factor at some point
it's so large it takes so much time to
send signal from left part of a brain to
the right part of a brain those are
essentially two separate agents and you
start having misalignment internally and
competition you split it up but it's
still a pretty large brain size Planet
size entities you can have what about
take say you have a trained neural
network could you then do some
interpretability and find a certain part
of it that's responsible for Dangerous
information or dangerous skills and then
delete that so so before I mentioned
training data and excluding things from
the training data but after you have the
model could you then delete parts of it
to make it more safe well almost
everything is dual use it's not like
okay just the nuclear weapons are
dangerous nuclear power can be used for
good or bad and it's same with
everything screwdriver hammer every
single concept every piece of knowledge
can be used for harm or for good so no
you can just delete the bad part of it
maybe that's a a general point about we
I mentioned before creating an AI
interpretability researcher or creating
an AI cyber security expert H when you
train say say you say you train or you
finetune on those skills will you then
inevitably get other skills that are
dangerous or could they be turned around
on you to say if you're very very
capable in cyber security you also know
a lot about how to infiltrate systems
and how to do hacking and how to you
know extract information from companies
all right so a perfect explainer a piece
of software like that would become a
tool in a toolbox of AI trying to
self-improve so if right now it's just
more comput and data at that point
you're giving this programmer access to
its own source code so maybe it will
take minutes instead of years what about
if we try to build more humanlike AI but
what we limited to uh robotics so we we
spend instead of trying to to create
basically an artificial person we in in
in a more cognitive sense in the sense
that they can read and write and and
process information like that what if we
try to to replicate what humans can do
at like walking or emptying a dishwasher
or something and limit it to that so you
we wouldn't be competing with AI in in
in more cognitive domains but we would
use AIS as as helpers in in a more kind
of physical things so not making more
intelligent systems is something I can
definitely Stand By and if you given
bodies to do more valuable economic
labor that's wonderful yes that's what
I'm saying there's trillions of dollars
of existing potential Lo in in the
models we have today we don't need to go
to the next level that quickly we have
not tapped into this potential but TR as
I understand it training or creating
actually a a robot that can empty a
dishwasher is more difficult than than
creating a language model that can write
a a passable high school essay and so
this is just how it it's turned out but
maybe we could spend our resources
differently which try to optimize for
robotics would that be a way a way
towards a more more safe development I
think there's a lot of effort Now to
create humanoid robots this was not the
case even five years ago and I think
once you add existing language model
like architectures to those bodies they
very quickly learn those manipulations
they learn from YouTube videos they
learn from watching human demonstrations
so I think it's just a question of where
do we want to emphasize put resources
and so far we did pure software because
it's cheaper you don't need to have
bodies factories I mean you just release
it now that people realizing okay there
is a big market for dishwashers I think
that's going to start being investigated
a little more and we'll get there very
quickly why do you think we'll get there
very quickly won't it require a an
entirely new architect you couldn't do
you couldn't train a a robot with a
Transformer like architect you could you
I I think you can because they already
do Vision processing they can can
explain an image they can create 3D
models of it they follow plans and
instructions if you ask it how to load a
dishwasher it knows better than I do I
think at this point it's a question of
putting it all together and kind of
running it in a physical environment to
iron out any like we forgot to plug it
in whatever problems but I think we
already have all the tools we need to
start monetizing this that's interesting
I that may create I mean imagine the
societal response to seeing actual
humanoid robots this is like this is I I
I think that the response would be
pretty strong to to having having a
robot a humanoid robot in walking around
or you know delivering the the post or
something of course I it depends on how
they look do they look uh kind of
passable or do they look like this
carton wheels that will have very
different impression and for many
different needs you need different
visual
representations if robotics is solvable
in the way you describe and and and we
we're just kind of on the verge of a
revolution is is that too too strong to
say or do do you think yeah what do when
do you think robotics will be will be
kind of solved to a human level so there
is two aspects to it one is technical
solution so I know Tesla's working on a
humanoid robot there are other companies
figure whatnot so they may get there in
terms of capability of Technology but we
saw it before when we first invented uh
video phones I think it was 1970s AT&T
had it but no one like bought one it was
expensive and no one else had one so it
wasn't adapted to use so it may be that
we have this robot capable of doing
dishes but it's like kind of expensive
and your wife is not interested in it
like I don't know what will happen but
it may be the case that we don't have
the proliferation happen as soon as we
have the capability I think from what I
see those models are capable of doing
prototypes today can probably do the
dishes does that argument also hold for
language models for example might we
just decide not to implement them in the
in the economy even though it it it it
could be so maybe it's it's too
expensive for companies to to fine-tune
them for their purposes and they're
worried about you know we don't want to
send our data to to Big American
corporations and could there be similar
holdups to to to the more kind of just
cognitive models or language models
there could be especially in restricted
domains like Academia for example
somewhat regular we don't want to be you
know replaced by AI we understand we
contribute very little on top of AI so
we're just going to legally protect
ourselves from having AI teaching online
courses and I'm going to be there
producing my own videos and lectures but
it's not a meaningful reason not to do
that and because the barrier to entry is
so much lower and millions of people now
tried it and have access and kids are
growing up with it I think it would be a
much easier transition than having to
buy this like
$10,000 piece of Hardware which I don't
know maybe it will strangle me in my
sleep because of hackers but think about
how much of the economy is a bit like
Academia in that it's heavily regulated
and there are vested interests in in you
know not wanting to be replaced I'm
thinking like the legal legal industry
or the medical industry or
Transportation much of the economy there
are lots of restrictions to
implementations that would mean that
implementation would be slowed down I
think it's possible a lot of it depends
on how measurable is what you produce so
in medicine you can measure things like
how many people died from the surgery
and things like that Academia is kind of
different we don't really measure how
knowledgeable our students are they get
a diploma and we're like oh look they
got jobs that's cute uh so it depends on
how real your field is some fields are
just by definition all about
participation and Prestige and you get a
degree but nobody actually measures
across the states students are ranked
from one to the last and you know which
university did the best job taking
students who are not so great and making
them greater versus taking the best and
making them the best I guess there are
some metrics that are optimized for in
in Academia but I I know I kind of know
what you're going to say but if I say
citations you're going to talk about
good heart's law right yes I will
absolutely yeah maybe maybe explain good
house law and also how that that's also
applicable to AI in a sense so the
moment you create some sort of defined
precisely defined way of explaining how
rewards are distributed people will find
a way to game it so if you say I will
reward you based on how many citations
you have and you're trying to get
rewards not science then you're just
going to publish survey papers because
they get thousands of citations doesn't
take long now with large language model
you can print one every day so that's
what you're going to do you are now
optimizing for citations and surveys is
a way to get there you're not producing
any valuable science really but you are
the best in the department and how does
this apply to AI where is the good
Hearts law where what metric are we
setting up to try to get good or safe or
reliable AI that that's then
good-hearted so all the historic
examples when we just started thinking
about AI safety people would propose
things like let's train AI to maximize
human smiles and the more Smiles the
more happy humans that means it's doing
so well but there are many ways to get
smiling humans you can do Taxidermy you
can do all sorts of things which is not
what we had in mind so the generality of
this law is that it's not like we picked
a bad thing to measure it's just the
moment you precisely say something I
will find a way to game it yeah it's
it's interesting how in how many domains
this kind of principles shows up there's
also the in evolution maybe you as soon
as you optimize for calories and then
you move a bit out of your evolutionary
domain then then you get the Obesity
epidemic all of these things in your
book you have a bunch of quotes from
historical experts and current experts
and so on I don't know if if it's just
the way you you wrote the book but it
makes it sounds like sound like we have
had these insights for 70 years 50 years
and and and as I'm reading your book I'm
becoming convinced that these are like
completely obvious points that we have
known for a while but there isn't there
isn't this consensus I think you would
agree that that your view isn't the
consensus view that AI is uncontrollable
and unverifiable and all these things so
not very scientific but I did run uh
kind of polls on Facebook and Twitter
and I'm not the most followed person in
the world but I have my you know 100,000
here and there and only a third of
respondents who are biased towards
liking my research and being aicy
interested on only a third set
controllable so the choices were
uncontrollable undecidable partially
controllable only a third was explicit
we definitely can control super
intelligence which means 2/3 absolute
majority don't think so maybe we just
never run the proper survey we keep
asking how soon before AGI maybe we
should ask do you think we can
indefinitely control super intelligent
machines I think the the best survey
data we have is is cat a Grace from from
from AI imp packs that surveyed
published authors at at large machine
learning conferences and there the
numbers are quite concerning also the PE
the timelines expectations to when we
will get ADI are dropping and the the
the expectations of of risks are
increasing you you've you've probably
read this survey what do you think of
the development from from the from the
previous survey to the to the most
recent it is to be expected you see this
amazing progress you're going to update
your timelines but kataa I have a
question to to your next survey and what
is that what is that question can super
intelligent machines be indefinitely
controlled of course yeah makes perfect
sense I want to perhaps End by you
giving us your vision or your what what
are the most fruitful uh research
directions we could look into
specifically for AI safety I should say
right so I'm working on what I think is
the most important part of it which is
figuring out what can we do and it's
impossible to do this maybe there is a
different tool which gets the job done
so I'm trying to look at those we now
have pretty successful record of
publishing a lot of peerreview Journal
papers there is a book there is ACM
survey what we don't get is a lot of
Engagement I would love nothing more
than to have lots of people publish
papers saying yski is completely wrong
here's why and here's how it actually is
possible to do all those things but so
far no one took up the challenge no one
is engaging people even say it's obvious
of course it's impossible to create bug
free software everyone knows it why did
you publish it or they say well yes but
what are we going to do let Chinese
build it first none of those anwers
meaningfully engaged with the results
meaningful engagement would be it's
against my personal interest to create a
device which will kill me a young guy
full of money I run this great company
I'm not going to do this stupid thing
this is not happening what would be
required for you to change your mind and
say okay AI is controllable what is
isn't the bar extremely high if if you
need a a formal proof that AI is
controllable that that seems extremely
difficult to do right so it's like
perpetual motion right so the patent
office does not reject patents for
perpetual motion machines but they
require that you submit a working
prototype I I think it's a fair
requirement for any impossibility
results either explain mistake in the
proofs and logic and mentation so
obviously Dumber agents can control much
smarter agents because and it scales or
create a prototype which scales so code
code code is truth you know if you can
do it but I don't think anyone makes
those claims no one is saying that they
have a working prototype or they know
how to get there they are just kind of
saying let's build it and see what
happens we'll figure it out when we get
there maybe it's going to turn out to be
friendly by default or we have no chance
we can't stop so we might as well not
stop some people have made the arguments
that that cats would be such a working
prototype it's kind of a a silly example
but the the argument is that cats are
living pretty decent lives they are
provided for by humans they have kind of
controlled Us in the sense that we
provide them food and they live in our
homes and even though they are not in
control at all in the world and they are
much dumber than we are they they seem
to be to be doing well in certain parts
of the world they also a menu in
restaurants from what I understand along
with dogs so I'm not sure if that's the
win we're looking for which lessons do
you draw from kind of species level
changes so the the the changes from
chimps to humans or you know this is
this is what this is one line of
argumentation that you that you hear
that that AI is going to be more like a
a species and and less like the tools
that we more like a new species
and less like the tools that we have now
and so we should be worried and the same
sense that chimps should be worried
about a humans evolving and and taking
power away from well anytime we had
conflict between a more advanced set of
agents and less Advanced doesn't have to
be cross spey even within human species
you know discovering new lands already
populated by people who don't have guns
it usually didn't end well for the less
capable agents historically just
genocide every single time yeah true
okay what about you've you've mentioned
a couple of times in this interview a
kind of positive Vision about what all
the good things we can get without super
intelligence maybe sketch that out a bit
more tell us about what what you think
what do you think is achievable with
current level models for example I think
if we probably deploy them we understand
how they work and where they can be used
and we get this development of humanoid
bodies coming along just a robotics
aspect of it I think almost all labor
physical and cognitive can be automated
so this is trillions of dollars to
economy I think narrow models can be
used for scientific research they don't
have to be Universal we saw it with
protein folding I think we can
understand human genome I think we can
get immortality definitely cancer cancer
is an infinite Loop you reset the loop
all those things can be done so we can
get health wealth we can use those tools
to help us better communicate and maybe
agree on some things within the human
community so maybe we'll get a little
better self-alignment again we we had
them for like a year this is brand new
we need time to figure out what they are
capable of instead we're like
immediately jumping to the next
Revolution before absorbing this one do
you think that the system of kind of
investing then now there's a lot of hype
and maybe that's Justified and maybe
there should even be more hype or less
hype whatever do you think this the
system can be stopped in any way because
you you You're Not Gon to G to make laws
about you you can't invest in Ai and so
the money is is going to be it's going
to keep pouring in so what is it kind of
what could we concretely do if if you
talk about if you're saying we should
explore these models and and maybe spend
a decade with with GPT 4 level models
what does that how do how do we
Implement that sh so I don't think there
is a law you can pass or anything like
that that would not work it doesn't work
to regulate this type of technology I
strongly believe in personal
self-interest if the CEOs of those
companies honestly believed my arguments
like this is not controllable and it's
dangerous it's against my self-interest
to do it so let's kind of all not do it
let's agree to stop do I think it will
happen in practice no absolutely not
each one of them it's prisoners dilemma
each one is trying to score before start
I asked you about the kind of the most
fruitful directions what so so so you're
working on impossibility results what
other directions do you find interesting
what what else do do do you see out
there that might be useful almost
everything is super interesting time is
limited so you have to like decide what
to work on we're not very good at
figuring out what needs to be done even
if we had this magical super intelligent
friendly gut we don't know what to order
of the menu so there are some things we
probably would agree and like no
diseases immortality but it's not
obvious what else is good I suspect Nick
bostrom's new book on Utopias may give
us some ideas for what to consider but
we as a Humanity have not spent a lot of
time thinking about what our purpose
should be what are your personal
thoughts there have you spent time
thinking about what we should do if we
if we get to a place of of extreme
abundance I I spent some time but it
feels like the is not a universal set of
terminal goals what happens is your
instrumental goals taken to extreme
become your terminal goals so you're
trying to secure future possibilities
resources
self-preservation capabilities for
future Discovery and that's not so bad
if we can secure ourselves as
individuals and as Humanity so we have a
backup plan we have a backup planet we
are interplanetary species in case of an
asteroid or anything like that that's a
good move in the direction of overall
long-term success if someone tells you
like okay the goal is to collect all the
stamps or specifically this religion
they probably don't have Universal
terminal goals calculated properly but
this general idea of securing what we
have and kind of growing in that
direction weirdly we do very little for
immortality not just in the sense of fun
research but even preserving what we
have we could have Universal cry
preservation as a tax benefit but no one
even talks about it that's not a thing
we talk about so things like that are
kind of easy to do if we cared about
important things but we don't in what
sense do you have hope for the future so
historically things always worked out
for us we had nuclear weapons we had
near misses but here we are if you told
me 5 years ago that we're going to have
a system as capable of GPT for
I would be very scared and yet here we
are and it's beautiful and no one is
dying so I was wrong about that I admit
when I'm wrong Maybe I'm Wrong about how
soon or how capable or how dangerous
they will be it's easy to see what
happens at the extreme if you take it to
the ultimate end but short term my paper
unpredictability holds you cannot
predict those things and that gives me a
lot of Hope oh so so unpredictability
gives you gives you kind of it it's also
a positive in that you can't predict it
so there's hope for it going well any
certain claims that it's definitely
going to kill everyone in two years no
you can't make that claim it could be
more than two years it could decide to
do something else as I said there are so
many variables it's cross domain other
things destructors can happen so while
you maybe as you said with your
investment analogy making money on
average you can be very wrong about
specific investment so that does give me
hope that my pessimistic Outlook could
be wrong if things begin going wrong do
do you do you foresee it being sudden
and catastrophic or do do you foresee it
being kind of like a gradual step up in
in harm so that perhaps you have an
accident involving a hundred people
before you have an accident involving a
thousand and then a million how how do
you how do you think this this might pan
out so I have a paper on historical AI
accidents and there is like a timetable
and it's become more frequent and more
impactful so this will continue we'll
have more impactful accidents more
people will be harmed maybe maybe Roman
mention some of these accidents for the
for the listeners so a common example
would be a system for detecting nuclear
weapons strike from an enemy coming in
was wrong about what it was observing
signaling that a war has started and if
it wasn't for human response not being
direct to where you just press fire back
we would all be that there is a common
example of Google releasing their
picture tagging software and being kind
of racist about tagging
African-Americans as not
African-Americans let's put it this way
the more impactful system is the more
domain it controls the more of the
impact that accident will have if it's a
spell checker it will misspell a word if
it's a spam filter it will delete very
important email but if it's a general
system controlling all the human
cyber infrastructure we don't know what
it's going to do I cannot predict it one
thing what seems to be the case is that
if it's not very bad 100 people die
thousand people die it's like a
vaccination people go see I mean this
happened AI failed and we still here
nothing happened it's not a big deal 100
people is nothing compared to 8 billion
and we just continue going forward so in
a way those partial failures are
actually enabling greater capabilities
development I that makes that makes
sense and that that that's perhaps what
what makes this this domain difficult in
the sense that you can't really the the
a critic or a skeptic about about AI
safety can also can can always kind of
point out to the to the history of
development so far and say things are
going well we are we are you know we're
benefiting and we haven't seen a bunch
of harms you've seen that argument
perhaps already with I don't know who
they're referencing when they make this
argument but the the the take is that
people were were complaining or
predicting a bunch of bad effects from
GPT 4 level models but those effects
haven't really come to fruition and so
we should discount the AI safety voices
so I I made the same argument I was
wrong about what a GPT for capable model
would actually do so yeah definitely
admit to that there is a famous analogy
with the turkey right every day Turkey
gets fed and it's wonderful until one
day near Thanksgiving something goes
different we never had a shift in AI
from narrow domain tool to General
domain agent that's a very different
paradigm shift from you know going gpt1
to gpt2 to GPT 4 AGI it's not the same
it feels the same way both software but
the capabilities jump is
unprecedented do you do you sometimes
worry that you are in a sense too
knowledgeable in in in this domain to be
to be to to learn something new from
people arguing with you what I'm
thinking of here is that all of the all
of the arguments I've made here today
you've probably heard them before and
you've probably heard a bunch of other
arguments and so you kind of you know a
lot about this domain you you're
professor of computer science and so on
do you do you worry that you you aren't
gaining new information and so you you
you keep kind of being reinforced that
AI will go wrong or that AI will be
uncontrollable because you you keep
hearing the same kind of like uh more
basic arguments that would be such a
wonderful problem to have to be so
knowledgeable but it's actually the
complete opposite in reality we produce
so many new papers so many results every
day I used to be able to read all the
papers in AI safety decade ago then I
was able to read all the good papers
then I was able to read all the papers
in the topic I'm working on now I'm not
even an expert and a narrow Dom main
papers I write so my paper and
explainability I haven't read 10,000
papers on that top I don't know if they
actually have some brilliant insights
I'm not aware of that's a huge problem
the segmentation in science we talked
about before is a big problem we may
already have solutions they are just
distributed throughout so many papers
and brains that we don't see the common
solution to this problem that's actually
an interesting question how much do you
think there would be to gain there just
imagine and again I we have discussed
all the reasons why we can't we we
probably won't get a system like this
but imagine you have an aligned scien
histic AI that is able to synthesize
across all domains and read all the
papers basically say this this system is
not allowed to do any any more
experiments nothing empirical what do
you think could be derived from the
knowledge base we have now looking at
interactions between different fields or
taking an inside from one field
combining it and and with a new field um
something like that it'd be huge so for
one I think so many results Great
results get published and noticed and
then 100 years later we're like the guy
published a paper about curing cancer we
just like didn't read that unpopular
Journal so that that those a historical
precedence we know like early work in
DNA by Mandel was not discovered until
much later things like that so that's
going to be obvious then there is direct
transfer of tools from one domain to
another they have this stool in another
department I never experienced it if I
had access to it all my problems would
be solved quite quickly finding patterns
is something AI is amazing at so we now
have this one data point in this field
one data point in the other field you
can do much with n equals 1 but then you
look at this nals 50 now you see the
whole picture clearly it's a pattern so
I I think it would be equivalent to all
the science down done so far okay so you
think it would be a huge effect actually
oh yeah okay I sometimes it's it seems
trivial to me that like there there
might be some the same question might be
discussed under different terms in
different fields or even in different
sub fields of the same discipline and
because people are so specialized they
are not interacting and so that we don't
get this knowledge out but yeah this is
one of the most positive uses of AI I
can think about as as kind of like a a
scientist working on gaining new
Knowledge from existing literature
absolutely that would be huge and in
general this is where we need a lot of
help we can no longer keep up with this
amount of new information books papers
podcasts I mean I can look at my to
watch list to read list it's just
growing exponentially larger and new
items get put on top but then pushed out
it's never going to happen without help
it's a common problem okay Roman thanks
for chatting with me again it's it's
been a real pleasure thank you so much
for inviting me